i really felt quite distressed and not
receiving an invitation maleficent calls
herself the mistress of all evil but is
she
really as terrible as she makes herself
out to be whether your favorite version
of the character is played by angelina
jolie or
straight out of disney's sleeping beauty
the real maleficent is
nothing like the disney versions it
turns out this famous witch is much more
than just a bad party guest
there are so many different versions of
maleficent out there that it can be
hard to keep track of which which is
which most of us probably got our first
introduction to the character in the
classic animated disney movie sleeping
beauty
this maleficent took not being invited
to a party really
seriously and showed up to curse
princess aurora
uh that's a major party foul maleficent
then we have the mistress of all evil
from the descendants franchise who's
played by actress kristen chenoweth
she's the mother of our hero mal
who does her best to fight for good
despite her decidedly evil background
in the abc show once upon a time she's
portrayed by kristin bauer van stratten
and curses both princess aurora and
prince philip
sleeping beauty's maleficent's party
invitation may have gotten lost in the
mail but that did not stop her from
getting her own live-action film series
starring angelina jolie
what a glittering assemblage king stefan
this series is unique because it gives
audiences a much more sympathetic
version of the character
and a tragic backstory just to top
things off
there's definitely no wrong version of
this character to have as a favorite but
the ones
most of us are familiar with are very
different from the original
as you've probably guessed from their
name the brothers grimm didn't have the
most cheerful tales to tell
but their version of the character isn't
actually the earliest one
classic fairy tales are filled with
wicked characters who often appear as
elderly women
treat firstborn children as a kind of
currency and make liberal use
of evil curses before the brothers grim
there was an italian writer giambattista
basili who spent the late 15th
and early 16th century creating and
collecting what are now known as some of
the oldest recorded fairy tales
one of his stories is called sun moon
and talia
and it later went on to serve as
inspiration for the tale we now know as
sleeping beauty
in this version a lord is told that his
daughter will be endangered by a piece
of flocks
so he bans the plant from his home his
daughter talia spins flocks with an old
woman
and winds up with a piece of it under
her fingernail which is enough to send
her into a seemingly unwakeable slumber
don't you just hate it when that happens
in sun moon antalya
the old woman isn't purposefully evil or
petty nor does she turn into a dragon at
any point
so she's clearly quite different from
most versions of maleficent we know but
it's not hard to see the inspiration
here
next up we have charles perrault another
famous author and fairy tale enthusiast
who has his own version of the tale
called the sleeping beauty in the wood
unlike gian batista basili's version
this one involves a number of good
fairies
eager to heap good fortune on a princess
and one old fairy who feels left out at
the party
the older fairy doesn't take too kindly
to being overlooked and decides to curse
the princess
to prick her finger on a spinning wheel
and pass away as a result
the remaining fairy negates the curse
enough so the princess falls asleep
instead
and the disgruntled fairy isn't seen
again and presumably
is not invited to any more parties now
let's take a look at little briar rose
from
jacob ludwig carl grimm and wilhelm carl
grimm
better known as the brothers grim in
this version
the king throws a celebration for the
birth of his daughter but with a limit
on the amount of fairies he can invite
due to the fact that he only had 12
golden plates a hosting dilemma that
we're all familiar with
so when the 13th fairy inevitably showed
up
she was livid about the lack of invite
and hurled a curse at the princess which
was then negated as much as possible by
another story
this version of the wicked fairy is very
similar to the one in the sleeping
beauty in the wood
and should inspire us all to consult our
guest lists a little more carefully
[Music]
it's not hard to see the similarities
between these fairy tales and how they
relate to more modern versions of the
story but there's an even earlier
version that exists
yet it's so often overlooked because
it's a romantic story
rather than a traditional fairy tale
purse of forest was written in french
anonymously
sometime between 1330 and 1345 and
wasn't translated until much later
instead of fairies the king invited
three goddesses to a party but
forgot to give themis the god of destiny
a knife what is it with these royals not
being able to pull off a proper party
themis may have been the goddess of
destiny but she clearly appreciates good
hospitality because she cursed the
queen's child to fall asleep after
pricking her finger
and not awaken until the splinter was
removed themis
may actually be the earliest version of
the character we know as maleficent
and she isn't just from this one
particular tale in greek mythology
themis was a titan who was often
associated with divine law
justice and customs and unlike
maleficent she wasn't known for being
mean or petty
quite the contrary themis wasn't
wrathful at all
and if she was disregarded then it was
the goddess nemesis who would step into
dolo punishments it's possible that more
modern versions of maleficent are
actually the result of a combination of
themis
and nemesis and that sleeping beauty
really dates back to the epic greek poem
dionysica
if you thought your vhs copy of disney's
sleeping beauty was old keep in mind
that this hails
from the late 4th or 5th century will
share a very um abridged version of this
20
426 line poem yeah the minor deity aura
got on the wrong side of artemis the
goddess of the hunt
so artemis asked nemesis to help her get
revenge
and nemesis convinced eros god of love
to cause dionysus to fall for aura
ariadne gives dionysus a disstaff to
present
aura with a disstaff being an early
version of what we now know today as a
spinning wheel
it's hard not to see the similarities
between nemesis and maleficent or the
fact that aura and aurora
sound quite similar and their stories
both involve a perceived slight
revenge and a spinning wheel type device
so in reality
the concept of a character like
maleficent is way older than most people
realize
thinking you could defeat me me the
mistress of all
evil disney's animated movie sleeping
beauty was released in 1959
and though it's considered a classic now
it actually did poorly at the box office
and represented disney's first annual
loss in over a decade at that point but
that's because of the high production
cost and mixed reviews from critics
not maleficent herself at least we think
in this version of the story
maleficent is much more of a villain
than in earlier versions of the story
in sun moon and talia she was just an
old woman that happened to facilitate a
spinning wheel mishap
then in the sleeping beauty in the wood
and little briar rose
she showed up at a party felt scorned
and set forth a curse that was in some
way mitigated by a less
salty fairy but in this disney version
maleficent is
much more insidious the maleficent most
of us know doesn't settle for cursing
princess aurora after she's not invited
to her christening she then seeks out
aurora
lures her into a room and transforms
into a spinning wheel for her to prick
her finger on
that's a lot more than previous versions
but
not quite enough to earn the nickname
mistress of evil
so maleficent captures prince philip and
imprisons him
then later becomes a dragon summons a
forest of thorns
and only stops after being stuck by
philip's sword of truth
disney's animated version of the
character was the cruelest up until that
point in time the princess
shall indeed grow in grace and beauty
yet disney was also responsible for
somewhat redeeming maleficent with their
live-action version
in previous versions of the story we've
seen the curse happy
seek revenge after being slighted in
ways that seem a little dramatic if
we're being honest
but the live-action maleficent actually
gave us a lot of backstory about the
character and why she had such a serious
grudge against the king
in this version she fell in love with a
peasant named stefan but eventually the
two grew apart
later stefan betrayed maleficent by
cutting off her wings to win the favor
of king henry as well as the crown for
himself
all of a sudden her missing party
invitation makes a lot more sense
and so does the fact that she shows up
anyway and curses king stefan's daughter
aurora and unlike previous versions of
the story
maleficent's spell isn't mitigated by
another fairy she makes it so true
love's kiss will break it which would
have been even nicer if she believed
love existed at the time in the end
maleficent comes to love aurora as a
daughter and it's her feelings that
ultimately free the princess from the
curse
even though this may be the most
powerful we've seen maleficent it's also
the most human we've seen this mighty
fairy her motivations are understandable
and she comes across as less petty and
obsessed with proper dinner party
etiquette than she does in other
versions
but don't worry i'll see you at the
christening
in the descendants we see a mighty
maleficent but she's as
evil as ever and just wants to use her
daughter mal as part of her wicked plans
we definitely don't want to see a sweet
mother-daughter type relationship like
we did between maleficent and aurora
and eventually mal is forced to break
away from her mother and resist her own
less-than-princess-like inclination for
evil
the maleficent from once upon a time is
very similar to the one from disney's
animated sleeping beauty just set in a
different time period
the events of this story take place
after the dark fairy was defeated by
aurora and philip and in this version
maleficent is still incredibly powerful
with the ability to transform into a
dragon and has a knack for getting into
mischief with her fellow evil doers
so now you might be asking which version
is the real maleficent
is it the earliest version where she was
more of a goddess lacking cutlery
or is it blasphemous to accept anything
other than the original
disney version of sleeping beauty don't
worry because we here at the things have
asked our fans and the answer is
you can't agree on one that's right each
version of the character is well loved
by many people and it's not hard to see
why
although these stories and characters
share similar elements they all have
their own special spin on things
there are some fans who appreciate the
more humanized live-action version
while others stand the petty animated
fairy this
is a great situation where there are no
wrong answers and learning more about
maleficent's past can help us
appreciate her all the more love
doesn't always end well beasty
this character proves not all fairies
are pixie dust and wishes
which version of maleficent is your
favorite do you appreciate the more
relatable elements of her story or do
you want to see her
full-on evil fairy share your opinions
with us and your fellow fans in the
comments section
and don't forget to click subscribe for
more videos from us here at the things